[Music]
descendants villains might be evil but
you have to admit that their fashion
sense is on point they have had quite
the transformation over the years stay
tuned to see which character had the
biggest fashion glow up don't forget to
hit that notification bell to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
do you like Camila Cabello BTS and
Ariana Grande come check out the trendy
a YouTube channel with the hottest music
news now let's check out these
descendants outfits wicked ways beneath
the skin let all who taste it now join
in
now you know we have to start with Mal
because there's so much to talk about
although she's the main character in The
Descendants franchise Mao has actually
gone through quite a lot of fashion
transformations over the years here's
how she looked in the very first movie
we absolutely love Mao's outfit because
there's just so much going on although
her color choices are quite dark you can
still catch a glimpse of almost neon
pink and green pieces this outfit was
still very fun although descendants
movies are pretty dark the first one
still had a very light atmosphere and
clearly Mao's outfit reflects it in the
second movie her outfits got a bit more
glam and detail she upgraded her shoes
from regular boots - absolutely gorgeous
high-heeled boots her outfit has more
green detail and her wig color and
styles slightly changed - her fashion
style definitely got a bit darker to go
with the theme of the second movie but
the biggest change will come in the
third movie for what it looks like
mouths wig is now more purple than ever
before and although her outfit still has
shades of green is also a lot darker and
resembles a one-piece more than separate
layers but you have to admit that she
looks gorgeous and all of these Eevee of
course we also have to talk about the
ultimate fashionista that is Eevee
[Music]
I made this dress out of an old curtain
and safety pins
Eevee's outfits took a very interesting
turn over the course of three movies in
the first movie she sported an awesome
looking blue kimono style blazer her
outfit was complete with accessories
like the gorgeous red necklace and
stylish black gloves and we were always
jealous of her skirt and leggings they
look amazing and she's totally pulling
them off in the second movie Evie's
outfit became slightly different as you
can see the blue colored kimono blazer
is no longer present it's been replaced
by an amazingly detailed dress and we
can't get enough of it seriously check
it out blue gold and red seem to be her
main colors for the second movie and her
outfit became much more sophisticated by
the third movie her look totally changed
her outfit is now primarily black and
red with shades of blue here and there
it's definitely one of the fashion
styles that changed the most although it
still looks like she's sporting a skirt
her top looks like it's a long sleeved
jacket definitely nothing like she's
worn before but we're here for it if you
had to choose between the three which
one would you go for Carlos seriously
everyone's outfits have gone through
quite the transformation over the course
of the three movies but no one has done
it quite as well as Carlos in the first
movie Carlos can be seen sporting an
outfit with surprisingly a lot of colors
you can spot some red white black and
even silver in there
his outfit consists of a vest t-shirt
and absolutely awesome looking pants in
the second movie carlos upgraded to a
long sleeves jacket we can see a lot
more red coming through and his outfit
is slightly more sophisticated
we're totally digging on the detail did
you spot the awesome crossbody satchel
and black gloves
it's a typical rebel villain kid look
and we're totally here for it
descendants - really nailed Carlos's
overall look and demeanor but it looks
like Carlos has really grown up by the
third movie check out those totally
awesome red boots
his outfit almost resembles a super cool
racing outfit we absolutely love the red
black and white combination but we're
kind of sad there will be no more silver
either way this is definitely a total
outfit glow-up and it really does prove
that Carlos is one of the few
descendants characters that can rock a
white outfit like no other
J and you know we have to talk about one
of our favorite characters his fashion
choice is pretty interesting and he
pulls it off in his own unique way
listen all you gotta do is look in the
very first movie J rocked a simple look
that got really detailed as the movies
went on in the first movie you could see
him in a colorful vest with simple jeans
and the red beanie by the second movie
his outfit got a lot more advanced just
look at the colors of his vest we can
spot red blue gold dark blue and even
yellow colors in there
they really make the entire outfit pop
don't they he also added some awesome
gloves and his beanie changed to dark
blue you can definitely tell that these
kids have gone through an amazing outfit
transformation most likely thanks to the
raised movie budgets it's so awesome to
see Jays fashion evolution dand by the
looks of it he's not done yet in the
third movie J sporting a much more
sophisticated outfit the colors aren't
popping as much as they did in the first
two did you notice that the beanie is
missing in this photo we hope he still
wears it for this movie dizzy dizzy
didn't appear in the first movie but she
was absolutely amazing and totally
memorable in the second she's just one
of those relatable characters everyone
loves but nothing's more relatable than
her awesome
eccentric outfits seriously we wish we
could wear that her outfit is made of a
gorgeous layered dress that's full of
color it just looks like she's
creatively splatter painted all over her
dress and made it ten times more awesome
as it would have looked without it it's
absolutely amazing by now we've also
seen glimpses of Disney's new fashion
for the third movie or well at least the
prequel to the third movie although the
trailer for under the sea was quite dark
you could see that her dress became
slightly longer it definitely still
looks like the same dress dizzy has worn
in the first movie but we have a feeling
it will become much more sophisticated
that's The Descendants fashion isn't it
of course Dizzy's also sporting a
mysterious necklace that kind of proves
this isn't even dizzy to begin with we
have a feeling this definitely isn't the
end of Disney's fashion we still have to
see what she'll look like in her auradon
prep outfits Gil Gil is also one of
those characters that
in the first movie but if he would be
things would definitely be different and
yep we'll talk about the other members
of the pirate gang too so stay tuned for
more fashion evolution but first let's
check out Gil and his I'm a pirate with
Dizzy's wardrobe outfit from the second
movie doesn't his vest look like it's
gone through a similar paint splatter as
Dizzy's dress he can definitely rock it
and we're loving the yellow gloves we're
totally in love with his pants but by
the looks of this behind-the-scenes
photo from the third movie he ditched
the yellow gloves and he went for a more
sophisticated color see absolutely
everyone has a glow up he also replaced
his crossbody satchel with really
cool-looking belt style straps the
pirate gang is definitely off to a good
start
so make sure you keep on watching if you
want to see Harry's and umas fashion
transformation it's actually amazing an
uma comes with a totally unexpected
twist when it comes to her outfit
transformation but first let's check out
another babe that managed to charm all
of our hearts and no it's not Harry hook
shad we don't have any insight yet into
what Chad Charming might look like in
the third movie but thanks to IMDB we
know that he's in it Chad might look
like a totally simple character on the
outside but the truth is he did go
through a fashion evolution of his own
his whole look changed check out this
photo from the first movie
Chad's actually wearing a relatively
normal outfit compared to other
characters it's a typical light blue
business suit with a yellow shirt
underneath nothing out of the ordinary
right but by the second movie chad
appears to have ditched the suit and
went for a blue sweater a yellow polo
shirt and a yellow pants this man in his
love for blue and yellow check out that
awesome blue watch on his wrist oh and
of course the major part of his
transformation was definitely his hair
it looks completely different by the
time the second movie rolled in and we
absolutely can't wait to see what Chad
will look like in the third do you think
that he'll still keep up his like blue
and yellow outfit or will the upgrade in
a new way
uma although uma hasn't appeared in the
first movie she quickly became
everyone's favorite character
a little unnecessary but it is so much
fun here's the deal she's absolutely
fantastic and so is her fashion that's
definitely not to be missed
apart from her gorgeous hair uma can
totally rock her look in the second
movie umas outfit was full of tassels
from jacket shoulders to her skirt she's
really rocking those tassels but her
outfit from the second movie is also
detailed af we love that belt detail
placed across her body and those boots
are totally made for walkin but it looks
like itll is going in a slightly
different direction in the third movie
at least judging by this
behind-the-scenes photo have you noticed
something unusual about Emma's blue
jacket the color is quite the same than
her clothes in the second movie but what
stands out is the jacket type it's
totally different from the clothes she's
worn before and not only that her jacket
looks pretty much the same as mouths
jacket from the first movie all that's
changed are the colors is this a hint
that the two might have reconciled their
friendship by the end of the third movie
or is it just a weird coincidence that
has nothing to do with one another we'll
have to wait and see Harry and here's
everyone's favorite eye candy Harry
hooks stole the show the moment he
showed up on our screens and fans have
been begging Disney to bring him back
for the third movie well we definitely
got our wish along with some behind the
scenes photos but first let's check out
what Harry looks like in the second
movie he's sporting his iconic eyeliner
a pirate hat a red vest and a ripped up
undershirt his signature colors are red
mixed with brown and it definitely works
but it looks like Harry has grown up by
the time to cast filmed the third movie
his character became much more
sophisticated and his eyeliner got
bolder seriously we're totally here for
his eyeliner he upgraded his vest along
with the rest of his outfit and it looks
amazing we can't even begin to describe
it but his look definitely matured while
still remained in the iconic pirate
style and then there's his awesome dark
hair does this mean that Harry totally
ditched his pirate hat we can't see it
but we hope he still has
speak up - there's definitely a lot more
in store when it comes to Harry and we
can't wait to see him on our big screens
once again outfit fashion predictions
with Cameron boys leaving Disney Channel
rumor has it that this could be the very
last descendants movie which also means
this could be the very last descendants
fashion show we'll ever see considering
there's quite a lot of behind the scenes
out there we have a feeling the main
characters won't just stick to a single
outfit throughout the entire movie and
who knows perhaps ullas wearing Mouse X
outfit really does mean the two will
become best friends after all that's
what we've also seen in one of the
behind the scenes photos since we're
getting a prequel to the movie we might
also get another set of amazing outfits
we've also yet to see what any of the
new characters will look like but we do
have one question how is Disney going to
recreate Haiti's iconic outfit that's a
challenge on its own we're sure dr.
facile ears character will also have an
interesting fashion as well as his kids
this movie is just so exciting we
absolutely can't wait to see it summer
2019 meets - hurry up what do you think
who had the biggest fashion
transformation come let us know in the
comments and that's it for our video
before you go make sure you check out
our friends at the trendy the best
channel for music related content they
did a recap of all DMA performances you
missed this year so go ahead and give
them a like thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]